Can we just like stay up here
all day it is so crazy down there
spider-man is in fact peter parker so peter
do what do i owe the pleasure when mysterio
revealed my identity my entire life got
screwed up this is hurting a lot of people
i was wondering if maybe you could make it so
that he never did the entire world is about
to forget that peter parker is spider-man
wait everyone mj ned may should really stop
be careful what you wish for parker
Hello Peter
Welcome back everyone marvel and sony released a
new version of the spider-man no way home trailer
as well as the official poster daring us to zoom
and enhance and try to find all the hidden details
so challenge accepted you know i'm something
of a scientist myself there are a couple hidden
details in here some of it's a little bit more
obvious so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we
also have the special disney plus day event
that's happening in a couple days on friday where
they're going to release a whole bunch of trailers
of course i'll be doing videos for all that
stuff i'm also doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do is enter is be a
subscriber and just post all the hidden details
that you found on this new poster please hold all
the mephisto memes i feel like we've had enough
of mephisto even though because spider-man no way
home and the whole premise of doctor strange spell
is based on a mephisto storyline in spider-man
one more day i feel like there's still going to be
a lot of mephisto jokes through spider-man
no way home but in this updated version of
the trailer there's a new version of the scene
where you see them falling through the landscape
to the other side as if they're entering
an alternate reality version of new york
and this is probably either after doctor strange's
spell is finished doing its work or more likely i
think it's when spider-man is fighting doctor
strange for that special box with the eye of
agamotto symbol on it that's the same symbol on
the ivagamoto amulet and it's the same symbol in
the window of all the different sanctums around
the planet it's part of the enchantment that
protects the earth using the sanctums together
from threats from beyond the main mcu universe
like this is meant to be a visual representation
of how the spell works when they're explaining it
to doctor strange you see it covering the entire
planet protecting it from beings like dormammu
shumagorth extra dimensional threats so in this
longer version of the scene where they're falling
through the landscape into this alternate reality
version where everything's warping around them
it's probably part of the different fight scenes
of them just battling it out with reality warping
all around them like this big train fight scene
here which talk about tobey maguire spider-man
multiverse easter eggs is a nice reference to
the spider-man 2 train fight scene with doctor
octopus like give me that train fight scene
again but with doctor strange this time and
make it a bunch of trains the whole idea with that
being that spider-man wants to undo the changes
that they made to the main mcu universe with the
spell because he thinks the spell only made things
worse classic spider-man and somehow he thinks
that whatever's in the box will fix everything so
it's a very local man ruins everything situation
it seems like whatever's going on with the box and
him trying to undo what they just did with the
spell is the key to the sinister six villains
escaping and it just makes everything worse it
would not be a spider-man movie if spider-man
somehow didn't cause most of the problems that he
has to solve but in the new official poster that
they released they basically confirm most of the
sinister six roster the official spider-man no way
home twitter account was also challenging everyone
to zoom in in hand so of course we have to oblige
challenge accomplished zoom in enhanced there's
the very obvious reference to this spider-man 2
tobey maguire poster with doctor octopus attacking
him his arms are in a similar attack pattern what
year is this don't you feel old having watched
this in the theater then zoom in hands over in the
upper right hand corner here there's the now very
obvious willem dafoe green goblin in a version of
his classic green goblin suit with the original
glider zoom in enhance even more this is a super
high-res version they were circulating to the
press so you get a much better look at the actual
costume you can see that he's wearing a version of
his helmet holding a pumpkin bomb the green goblin
armor suit just looks a little more polished than
the classic tobey maguire spider-man movie version
but i think it's the same thing that's going
on with the way they're doing doctor octopus in
this new spider-man no way home movie using more
advanced modern special effects to dh everyone and
just make it look way shinier like it's meant to
be the same doctor octopus same arms same clothing
same jacket from spider-man 2 and he's supposed to
be the same basic age as if no time has passed for
him after the end of spider-man 2 but because of
the modern special effects and because it's not
absolutely perfect it just seems a little bit
different even though it's not really supposed
to be so i know you're asking now why is green
goblin's suit look all shiny and brand new and
just like it did during the original spider-man
movie with tobey maguire if they destroyed it
at the end of that movie i did a video a while
ago for a preview of his suit in the movie and
it actually showed a lot of the wear and tear
and some of the repairs that he had made to it
with a very comic book accurate strap that he was
wearing he wasn't wearing the green goblin helmet
in these pictures so what might be happening is
that he just has a couple different versions of
the green goblin costume throughout the movie like
there's the idea that doctor octopus might also be
stealing spider-man's iron spider nanites like the
iron man technology to upgrade his octopus arms so
the same idea might be true of some of the other
sinister six villains like obviously electro's
lightning is yellow now so we know they're making
some changes to the characters even though they're
meant to be the versions from the topia mcguire
spider-man movies in the andrew garfield amazing
spider-man movies speaking of which there's the
arcs of jamie foxx's electro lightning across
the sky now yellow like i said i think the reason
why they're making the lightning yellow is just
to make him more comic book accurate because he's
supposed to be the same version they'll probably
just have a way of explaining him absorbing
different kinds of energy and that'll probably be
the reason why his lightning changes colors then
in the lower half of the poster in the background
here you see the dust trail forming into a shape
arcing around for the tobey maguire version
of sandman from spider-man 3. he's shown up a
couple times during the trailers but we haven't
seen too much from him like there are a couple
clearly identifiable sinister six characters
but for those of you asking what's going on here
in all the rubble like there's a lot going on here
in the bottom half of the poster some of it looks
kind of molten like something's on fire there's
sparks flying around in the background are there
other sinister six villains hidden in the shadows
or other parts of the poster because they already
confirmed the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
version of the lizard would be featured in
that last empire preview a couple weeks ago
so if you look at this piece of rubble zoom and
enhance these are the highway treads like the
grooves in the road so this rubble is probably
meant to signify the big george washington bridge
fight scene in all the trailers but you ask does
that mean that spider-man will be fighting all
the sinister six villains here during that bridge
fight like is the scene they depict in the poster
meant to be an accurate representation of the
scene during the movie i'll say right now without
more evidence maybe not but there'll probably be
at least a couple sinister six villains during
that bridge fight scene my early theory right
now just based on the trailer footage so far
is that because we saw the goblin bomb on the
highway it's just doctor octopus and green goblin
in that george washington bridge fight there's the
separate footage of him in the black suit finding
electro and sandman at night that seems like a
completely different part of the movie so what
they might be doing is just having the sinister
six films pair off and tag team him together in
different groups but as for other hidden sinister
six villains on the poster some of you claim that
you can see lizard's tail in the shadows falling
on spider-man's iron spider suit here but i don't
see that anywhere in the poster here i do think
that yes this is lizard swiping him in doctor
strange's underground prison in this room of the
sanctum during this particular trailer scene but
let me know in the comments if you feel like you
are absolutely sure you can see any other sinister
six villains here in the background or hidden
details that i didn't talk about during the video
i am sure a bunch of people just spent all night
and all morning looking for tobey maguire and
andrew garfield's spider-man versions in the
poster too in the background but i've said
it before i think they're probably going to hold
off as long as possible on revealing their roles
in the movie and i think they're only going
to be different levels of cameo scenes like
a really good example i just did a couple eternals
videos about the post-credits scene the mid-credit
scene with the special secret cameos they have
in the movie and the director has been talking
about the special cameo scenes openly for the past
several days you've probably seen it all over your
timeline but the main marvel account still has not
posted anything about any of them in in fact they
waited till this morning like a couple days after
the movie actually came out to officially release
a poster of kit harrington's dane whitman not
a black knight poster not an ebony blade poster
just a regular old kit harrington dane whitman
poster marvel's really weird about posting stuff
like that like the director of the actors had
been talking about those cameo scenes for at
least the last week or two almost so it's all over
everyone's timelines everyone knows what's going
on but marvel for some reason just really holds
off on posting about stuff like that speaking of
post-credits scenes you're asking what about venom
is he going to be in any of the trailers featured
in any of the posters the promos or anything like
that because the venom looked to be carnage post
credit scene but i think the idea with venom just
based on the way the sony people were talking
about it like andy serkis and tom hardy is that
venom will probably just show up in some kind of
spider-man no way home post credit scene just to
have the marvel people reference the venom post
credit scene from the mcu side of things the next
real big spider-man no way home trailer probably
won't be released till either next week or the
week after that but sometime before the end of
the month really big reminder about disney plus
day they're doing a big presentation this friday
with a bunch of trailers there's a rumor they're
gonna drop the star wars obi-wan kenobi trailer
maybe a moon night trailer maybe a she-hulk
trailer and more hawkeye trailer footage
probably a couple surprises and they'll probably
reveal some of the marvel disney plus series that
they're working on that we don't know about yet
so whatever it is they post whatever trailers
of course i'll do videos for everything
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of that everyone
click here for my eternals post credit scene
video and click here for my full eternals movie
breakdown with easter eggs for the entire movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!